[Musik]
und jetzt
heute journal mit heinz wolf uns
marietta slomka guten abend der
bundeskanzler ist heute in polen eine
seiner ersten station nach seinem
amtsantritt
wie schon zuvor außenministerin baerbock
setzt er mit der frühen reise ins
nachbarland auch ein zeichen erst nach
frankreich und zur eu in brüssel und
dann direkt nach warschau die polen
werden das aufmerksam zur kenntnis
nehmen und schätzen aber leichter wird
der besuch dadurch auch nicht das
verhältnis ist belastet das gilt
natürlich nicht nur für deutschland die
eu insgesamt ist er im konflikt mit
polen und auch ungarn aber den deutschen
nimmt die polnische regierung kritik
besonders übel einem brühl hat olaf
scholz in warschau beobachtet
es gab wohl einiges zu besprechen
zwischen dem deutschen kanzler und dem
polnischen ministerpräsidenten
die beiden ließen sich jedenfalls zeit
bis sie in warschau vor die presse
traten ein besuch beim nachbarn bei dem
klartext geredet wurde
europa ist eine werte- und
rechtsgemeinschaft uns verbinden die
vorstellung von rechtsstaatlichkeit und
demokratie und deshalb wäre es auch sehr
gut und hilfreich wenn die diskussionen
und gespräche zwischen der europäischen
union der kommission und holen weil zu
einer sehr guten pragmatischen lösung
führen könnten rosmarie joss situation
wir haben über die situation in der
ukraine gesprochen das ist unser
direkter nachbar ein nachbar der durch
die eröffnung der neuen gas verbindung
nord stream 2 in einer schlechten
schwierigen lage ist auch wir sind in
einer schwierigen lage auch polen die
slowakei andere osteuropäische länder
können den erpressungen von russland
unterliegen und warum
russen bei allen unterschiedlichkeiten
eines betonten beide seiten die
wichtigkeit der deutsch-polnischen
freundschaft die verantwortung durch die
gemeinsame geschichte
der umgang damit noch so ein heikles
thema
schon länger hängen in warschau plakate
die deutsche politiker in eine reihe mit
goebbels und hitler stellen und von
deutschland reparationen fordern
finanziert aus mitteln des polnischen
kulturministeriums seit heute ist ein
motiv dazu gekommen ein neuer kanzler
die harten töne bleiben
wir haben das thema entschädigungen
erwähnt ein thema von großem leiden die
polen während des zweiten weltkriegs
erlitten hat das ist nicht nur ein meer
von tränen unserer mütter ein meer von
blut unserer väter sondern wir haben
noch die chance auf eine normale
entwicklung verloren
wir haben verträge geschlossen die
gültig sind und die fragen für die
vergangenheit und die
entschädigungsleistung geregelt haben
dass es sehr gut so dass das gelungen
ist trotzdem fühlen wir uns weiter
verpflichtet auch im hinblick auf die
moralischen
konsequenzen der vielen zerstörungen die
deutsche in polen angerichtet haben und
die auch in vielen anderen orten der
welt
der umgang mit der vergangenheit eine
gemeinsame zukunft in europa es bleibt
schwierig für deutsche und polen
dass olaf scholz in warschau auch
explizit auf nord stream 2 angesprochen
wurde ist für ihn durchaus heikel die
spd hat bisher zu dem projekt gestanden
allen voran manuela schwesig für die die
pipeline in mecklenburg vorpommern eine
erhebliche wirtschaftliche bedeutung hat
die grünen hingegen haben sich dazu
immer ablehnend positioniert und
annalena baerbock macht auch nicht den
eindruck als wolle sie jetzt als
außenministerin ihre kritische haltung
dazu aufgeben das wurde jedenfalls in
dem interview deutlich dass ich heute
nachmittag mit ihr geführt habe darin
äußert sie sich über das verhältnis zu
russland und china
zwei der schwierigsten themen mit denen
sie es zu tun hat und über die teils
auch morgen beim eu außenrat in brüssel
gesprochen wird zuvor aber noch der
bericht von thomas reichert über die
deutsche außenpolitik unter neuer
regierung
es ist beim ersten g 7 treffen der neuen
deutschen außenministerin nicht anders
als sonst wenn sich die großen
industrienationen des westens treffen
öffentlich erklärt wird nur worüber man
sich einig ist etwa die warnungen an
russland vor einem angriff auf die
ukraine das ungeklärte ungelöste aber
das ist nicht für die mikrofone
wir haben gezeigt dass wir für freiheit
und demokratie stehen und für das recht
der menschen überall frei von
unterdrückung zu leben in diesem zu
verständnis wollen wir als g7 staaten
eine zusammenarbeit mit china unter
fairen bedingungen und vereinigen
achtung der menschenrechte die usa und
großbritannien haben wegen chinas
verletzung ebendieser menschenrechte
einen diplomatischen boykott der
winterspiele in peking angekündigt und
deutschland die ampel es ist ungeklärt
gelöst dabei hatte den job von john
große hoffnungen auf die neue regierung
in berlin der täter kam wegen eines
kritischen dokumentarfilms zu chinas
sommerspielen 2008 für jahre in haft
später bekam er asyl in den usa gelangen
wollte in berlin für einen olympia
boykott werben aber dort hatte kaum
jemand zeit für ihn gute mit den spielen
ist es so die ganze welt kommt zusammen
das ist eine schöne sache aber doch
nicht an einem ort wo millionen von
menschen in angst und schrecken leben
müssen und sich nicht darüber beschweren
dass
in china steht schon alles bereit für
die große show und peking tut was es
meistens tut es droht den kritikern den
boykott ländern und schmeichelt den
unentschieden
wir glauben dass die neue deutsche
regierung ihre pragmatische und
ausgewogene china politik beibehalten
china entgegenkommen und beziehungen mit
gegenseitigem respekt und nutzen
entwickeln wird
übersetzt heißt das peking verlangt dass
in berlin alles bleibt wie es unter
merkel war wohl wissend dass der
koalitionsvertrag eine härtere
chinapolitik ankündigt auf der grundlage
der menschenrechte und des geltenden
internationalen rechts suchen wir die
kooperation mit china wo immer möglich
die tinte unter dem vertrag ist noch
kaum trockener ist dieser satz schon
gegenstand des ersten ampel streits für
die grünen bedeutet er kein
regierungsmitglied wird zu den peking
spielen fahren für die spd bedeutet er
am ende entscheidet olaf scholz
außenpolitik ist im kabinett eine
gesamtleistung und natürlich
insbesondere auch von der
außenministerin von der
verteidigungsministerin von der
entwicklungshilfe ministerin aber
natürlich insbesondere von olaf scholz
für die grünen klingt das als falle die
ampel zurück hin gerhard schröders
zeiten der sich selbst als koch den
kleineren koalitionspartner nur als
kellner sein jetzt geht eine ressort
hoheit bei der außenministerin und eine
richtlinienkompetenz beim kanzler und
sie werden miteinander reden nur das
koordinieren wie es sich gehört und
sonst wird diese regierung keinen erfolg
haben die ampel sorgt es gehe jetzt um
eine einheitliche position europas zu
den spielen in peking morgen john sorgt
dann soll es nicht nur bei worten
belassen sondern handeln er selbst wäre
ohne das nie frei gekommen und heute
nicht hier
und die neue außenministerin annalena
baerbock sonst aus brüssel zugeschaltet
guten abend frau berbalk schönen guten
abend sie haben ja eine eine werte
geleitete außenpolitik angekündigt auch
mit einem jahr härteren vorgehen
gegenüber autoritären staaten da kann
man direkt mal loslegen und fragen wie
stehen sie selbst dann zu einem boykott
der winterspiele in peking
erstmal sind olympische spiele und ich
habe jahrelang sehr intensiv sport
gemacht ein festes sport ist da bereiten
sich sportlerinnen und sportler
jahrelang manchmal ihr halbes leben lang
darauf vor und deswegen sollte das jetzt
nicht für politische dinge oder
zeremonien genutzt werden und das gilt
umso mehr mitten in einer pandemie und
wir haben ja immer wieder deutlich
gemacht wie wir die menschenrechtslage
auch in china in diesem moment sehen
auch angesichts der vorfälle die es in
jüngster vergangenheit gegeben hat auch
mit blick auf sportlerinnen sportler und
auf dieser grundlage werden wir jetzt
morgen hier in brüssel gemeinsam mit
unseren europäischen kollegen darüber
beraten da ist jetzt noch nicht so ganz
deutlich geworden wofür sie plädieren
ich glaube das kann man schon ein
bisschen raus hören wofür ich plädiere
aber ich bin ja vor ein paar tagen auch
nach brüssel gereist mit einer haltung
das für mich gemeinsame europäische
außenpolitik nicht bedeutet jeder kommt
mit seinem statement wasser zu hause
aufgeschrieben hat angereist dann lesen
27 ministerinnen und minister ihre
nationalen statements vor dann denkt man
das ist eine gemeinsame europäische
außenpolitik sondern dass wenn man
gemeinsam agieren will man erst
miteinander spricht da hat man natürlich
eine haltung die position mit der man
reingeht und dann auch mit möglichst
klappt es nicht mit allen 27 aber mit
mehreren dann am ende auch gemeinsam
raus zu kommen ist das jetzt so ein
bisschen in direkte kritik an frankreich
denn die haben sich ja schon klar
positioniert man findet das ist
symbolpolitik wenn man da nicht hin
reist sollte man lassen das ist gar
keine kritik an irgendjemanden sondern
das ist die grundlage auf der wir uns
zwar nicht nicht nur alleine als
außenministerin sondern wir in dieser
koalition eine kohärente europäische
außenpolitik in zukunft gestalten wollen
die frage ist ja wie siena darauf
reagieren würde einige länder haben sich
ja bereits positioniert also die usa zum
beispiel kanada großbritannien an gesagt
wir werden einen diplomatischen boykott
machen und china hat gesagt dass werde
konsequenzen haben also auch ganz klar
gedroht wie wirkt das auf sie
das zeigt was für einer schwierigen welt
wir gerade leben ich meine einfach
wasser noch nie auf diesem planeten aber
wir sind in einer situation wo wir eben
erneute spannungen haben wo wir auch und
das habe ich ja immer wieder deutlich
gemacht gerade mit blick auf china
eigentlich viele viele themen hätten wo
wir kooperiert kooperieren müssten
deswegen china ist auch partner für uns
als europäer für die g7 bei vielen
globalen fragen kann man dinge nur
gemeinsam lösen aber eben auch
wettbewerber und in manchen dingen
system rivale und deswegen ist das
dilemma manchmal in einer außenpolitik
gemeinsam zu kooperieren und kooperation
ist das oberste gebote von diplomatie
und internationaler zusammenarbeit aber
eben dass es die haltung von liberalen
demokratien das immer auch auf grundlage
von menschenrechten und internationalen
verträgen zu machen aber an ihrer idee
von einem teilweisen importverbot für
bestimmte ware aus in jena besonders
problematischen region shenyang in china
daran halten sie fest oder ist das vom
tisch
also darüber haben wir jetzt im detail
nicht bei g7 gesprochen aber das ist die
grundlage unseres koalitionsvertrages
dass wir die stärke des europäischen
binnenmarktes nutzen und das bedeutet
dass wir eben nicht nur eine
gemeinschaft europäerinnen und europäer
von gütern sind und das ist auch für
mich die lehre aus der globalisierung
der letzten jahre das nicht automatisch
wirtschaftskooperation zu einem fairen
miteinander führt sondern dass man schon
werte und regeln selber setzen muss und
das bedeutet zum beispiel dass produkte
aus zwangsarbeiter nicht auf den
europäischen markt kommen können genauso
wie produkte aus kinderarbeit nicht in
einem binnenmarkt gehören der auf den
werten der menschenrechte gebaut ist
stichwort menschenrechte und stichwort
völkerrecht die drohung und russlands
gegenüber der ukraine haben ja auch bei
dem g7 treffen bei dem sie jetzt waren
eine große rolle gespielt wird mit
massiven konsequenzen gedroht bohren
sollen die denn bestehen diese
konsequenzen das ist ja nicht so klar
definiert worden
wir haben gemeinsam viele viele stunden
nicht nur gesprochen sondern auch mit
hochdruck hat es ja im vorfeld
telefonate gegeben zwischen präsident
biden und präsident putin wohl noch
einmal deutlich gemacht wurden ist auch
jetzt im nachklapp auf dem g7-gipfel von
uns als außenministerin und
außenminister dass die souveränität der
ukraine für uns grundlage für alles
handeln und für alle gespräche ist aber
dass die tür für gespräche immer und
jederzeit offen steht und dass wir
gemeinsam mit russland möglichst im
normandie format was es ja schon mal
gegeben hat jetzt wieder an den
gesprächstisch zurückkehren müssen sie
wissen aber auch dass die verbündeten
insbesondere auch die usa aber nicht nur
eine ganze reihe europäischer länder da
gibt es wirklich eine mehrheitsmeinung
von deutschland erwarten dass nord
stream zwei die pipeline die gas
pipeline zur disposition gestellt wird
und sie selbst die grünen partei
erwartet das ja eigentlich auch haben
sie eine chance sich dagegen die spd
durchzusetzen oder ist das wäre das
verlorene liebesmüh
auch darüber haben wir im rahmen der
koalitionsverhandlungen gesprochen und
deswegen im koalitionsvertrag verankert
dass für energieprojekte und dazu
zählten austria 2 europäisches
energierecht gilt und das bedeutet dass
nach jetzigem stand diese pipeline so
nicht genehmigt werden kann weil sie
eben die vorgaben des europäischen
energie rechts nicht erfüllt und die
sicherheitsfragen ohnehin noch im raum
stehen und auch das wurde ja mit den
amerikanern noch von der alten
bundesregierung mit besprochen dass bei
weiteren eskalationen diese pipeline so
nicht weiter ans netz gehen könnte ich
benutze den konjunktiv wir sind ja
gerade in der phase dass wir gemeinsam
alles dafür tun wollen dass gespräche
wieder stattfinden können bei gespräche
das beste und sicherste mittel dafür
sind dass es nicht zu einer weiteren
eskalation kommt das wird noch
interessant frau berben ich danke ihnen
bis hierhin für dieses interview danke
ebenso alles gute
wie in einem kriegsgebiet auch unsere us
korrespondenten sind geschockt über das
was sie in kentucky zu sehen bekommen
die verwüstung durch die tornados ist
wirklich furchtbar und geht weit über
das hinaus was solche wirbelstürme
normalerweise anrichten sowieso ist es
ungewöhnlich dass um diese jahreszeit so
heftige wirbelstürme beziehungsweise
windhosen übers land ziehen die
klassische tornado saison wie sie in den
usa genannt wird ist eigentlich im
frühjahr es sind mehrere bundesstaaten
betroffen aber am schlimmsten sieht es
in kentucky aus dort gibt es auch die
meisten toten die behörden befürchten
dass mehr als 100 menschen ihr leben
verloren haben dina niebergall berichtet
alle packen mit an den mayfield kentucky
räumen auf was von ihren häusern übrig
ist und hoffen dass hier unter den
trümmern keine toten finden
der 27-jährige clayton ist mit einer
gruppe von soldaten extra angereist um
zu helfen
ich weiß dass viele leute opfer
herausgezogen haben tote das ist
emotional und bewegend und das macht das
alles sehr real
viele gebäude in den usa sind nur aus
holz gebaut die zerstörung fällt daher
umso heftiger aus aber selbst das
stahlgerüst dieser kerzenfabrik hielt
nicht stand alleine hier sollen
mindestens 70 menschen ums leben
gekommen sein der sturm kann zu schnell
und war außergewöhnlich stark
es gab viele warnungen tatsächlich gab
es sogar in dieser fabrik eine warnung
für die leute sich in die richtigen
schutzbereiche zu begeben aber dieser
sturm ist schlimmer als alles was wir
zuvor gesehen haben
der gouverneur schickt die nationalgarde
um besonders betroffene gebiete wieder
aufzubauen der us-präsident hat
zusätzliche hilfe versprochen und auch
clayton will nicht aufgeben
ich will weiter hoffen diese tragödie
verschont niemanden
sie sucht sich nicht aus welche seite
sie angreift oder ob jemand einer
bestimmten politischen richtung folgt
wenn du betroffen ist kommen wir um zu
helfen
diese hilfe wird kentucky aber auch die
umliegenden bundesstaaten brauchen
vermutlich viele wochen lang
und jetzt erstmal die nachrichten von 15
großbritannien ist wegen der ausbreitung
der neuen omikron variante die korona
waren stufe angehoben worden durch das
auftauchen der besonders ansteckenden
variante könnte das gesundheitssystem
weiter belastet werden erklärte die
gesundheitsbehörde
warnstufe von drei auf vier steigend die
zweithöchste stufe premierminister
johnson rief in einer am abend im
fernsehen gezeigten ansprache angesichts
dieser lage dringend zur impfung auf das
programm für booster impfungen werde
noch einmal beschleunigt so johnson
bundesinnenministerium feser warnt vor
einer zunehmenden gewaltbereitschaft der
querdenker bewegung der
verfassungsschutz beobachtete diese
gruppe noch intensiver so felser zur
funke mediengruppe bei protesten gegen
die korona maßnahmen im thüringischen
greiz gestern abend wurden 14 polizisten
verletzt rund 1000 menschen hatten sich
versammelt protestierende haben versucht
eine polizeikette zu durchbrechen
die beamten setzten daraufhin
pfefferspray ein
die europäische kommission hat im streit
zwischen frankreich und großbritannien
um fischereirechte im ärmelkanal einen
durchbruch verkündet wie die kommission
mitteilte habe die britische regierung
weitere lizenzen an eu schiffe für das
fischen in britischen gewässern sowie
vor der kanalinsel jersey vergeben
seitdem eu austritt großbritanniens
müssen frankreichs fischer lizenzen
beantragen und das tauziehen darum hatte
seit monaten für streit gesorgt
israels regierungschef benjamin
abo dhabi eingetroffen und wird sich
morgen mit kronprinz mohammed bin sajed
treffen es ist der erste offizielle
besuch eines israelischen
premierministers in den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten vor dem abflug sagte
bennett es gehe bei der besuch vor allem
darum die beziehung der beiden länder
weiter zu normalisieren und
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit zur
förderung seit 2020 nähern sich die
beiden länder diplomatisch an
wenn mit omikron eine noch anstecken
dürre corona variante anruf befürchten
virologen und auch ärzte dass auch die
zahl der kinder steigen könnte die eine
infektion nicht gut wegstecken was sind
anteilig zwar wenige aber auch da wirkt
die wucht der großen zahl in der masse
führen dann auch kleine prozentzahlen zu
vielen fällen und klinikbetten
insbesondere intensivbetten gibt es für
kinder viel weniger als für erwachsene
man könnte sie auch nicht einfach auf
erwachsenen stationen verlegen die
behandlung von kindern ist nicht ohne
grund ein spezialgebiet der medizin
tatsächlich waren die kinderkliniken in
den letzten wochen ziemlich voll nicht
wegen krone sondern wegen rsv
infektionen das ist eine ungewöhnlich
große welle gibt hat aber wohl auch mit
corona zu tun berichtet dominik
löschmeister
angefangen hatte es mit einem schnupfen
doch dann in der nacht hörte maria auf
zu trinken musste in die kinderklinik
ein test bestätigte maria hat rs fahrer
ein atemwegsinfekte bei kindern der vor
allem für säuglinge gefährlich sein kann
heftiger und geht halt wirklich ganz
klein und dachte man schon angst wenn
dann gesagt wird dass es zum
atemstillstand führen kann und das jetzt
schon zu sagen
dass respiratorische sind sozial virus
ist bei säuglingen und kleinkindern der
häufigste auslöser für atemwegsinfekte
in den allermeisten fällen verläuft rsv
harmlos mit schnupfen und husten ein
fall für chef hans lothar schrod wird
rsv vor allem bei babys in den ersten
lebensmonaten und kindern mit
chronischen erkrankungen
manche dieser kinder müssen beatmet
werden neu ist dass in diesem jahr rsv
so häufig auftritt
und das hat etwas mit den schließungen
der kindertagesstätten und den schulen
zu tun im letzten winter dadurch hat
keine auseinandersetzung in der
bevölkerung mit dem video stattgefunden
das betrifft die geschwister kinder und
die erwachsenen auch und von daher sind
die jungen kinder jetzt völlig gefährdet
auch die wartezimmer der kinderärzte
sind voll rückert hat im vergangenen
winter durch masken kita und
schulschließungen nur sehr wenig infekte
in seiner praxis erlebt jetzt dabei
schieße die zahl der kinderkrankheiten
in die höhe so etwas sei in den 15
jahren in denen er seine praxis hat noch
nicht vorgekommen
normalerweise ist es so im schnitt in
den wintermonaten ist mal so ein kind im
monat oder alle zwei wochen ein kind wo
es mal kritisch krank wird in dieser
saison war das jetzt letzten wochen
ungefähr zwei pro woche die wirklich
kritisch krank waren hinzu kommt schon
lange sind kinderkliniken in deutschland
unterfinanziert viele können nur
überleben weil sie von anderen
fachbereichen in den krankenhäusern
mitfinanziert werden so trifft der hsv
auf sowieso schon überlastete
kinderkliniken
die bettenzahl in der kindermedizin hat
abgenommen zweifelsohne
wir haben auch kürzere verweildauern das
geht über das ganze jahr gesehen bekommt
man mit den kapazitäten zu recht aber in
der kindermedizin gibt es immer diese
sehr starken saisonalen schwankungen
und das abrechnungssystem führt
natürlich dazu dass diese vorhaltungen
ausreichende kapazitäten nicht
ausreichend refinanziert werden
in den nächsten wochen rechnen sie in
der kinderklinik frankfurt-höchst mit
weiteren rsv fällen der winter beginnt
erst der kleinen maria aber geht es
inzwischen wieder besser
wir bleiben noch beim thema gesundheit
dass eine chronische infektion auch für
junge gesunde menschen weit mehr ist als
ein schnupfen das hat ja auch joakim ich
erfahren müssen und hat darüber mit dem
zdf gesprochen der
fußball-nationalspieler user kimmig
lässt sich nun doch gegen korona impfen
seine meinungsänderung erklärt der
bayern profi in einem zdf
exklusiv-interview zu sehen unter
sportstudio de noch pausiert der
26-jährige
im nächsten jahr könnte kim ich bei den
bayern wieder voll mitspielen
flüssigkeit in der lunge verhindert
vorerst intensives training nach einer
corona infektion mit milden symptomen
im oktober war der nationalspieler in
die kritik geraten als er öffentlich
gemacht hatte aus persönlichen gründen
nicht geimpft zu sein davon rückte jetzt
ab natürlich wäre es besser gewesen mich
früher impfen zu lassen generell
war es für mich einfach
sehr schwierig mit meinen ängsten
bedenken umzugehen und deshalb war ich
auch so lange unentschlossenen deshalb
konnte ich diese entscheidungen zu dem
zeitpunkt auch nicht treffen chemie
stimmt termin steht noch nicht fest
zunächst hat er den status eines
genesenen von folgeschäden für sich geht
der 26 jährige nicht aus
die ergebnisse aus der
fußball-bundesliga von heute greuther
fürth hat 1 zu 0 gegen union berlin
gewonnen tor reicht das zweite
sonntagsspiel eintracht frankfurt bayer
leverkusen 5 zu 2 zum wintersport da
machten die damen in den deutschen
zweierbobs heute die podestplätze unter
sich aus siegerin laura nolte feierte in
winterberg den dritten sieg im vierten
rennen
bei den herren fuhr von jasper friedrich
seinen nächsten sieg im viererbob ein
und baut damit sein weltcup konnte auf
60 siege aus
sehr spannend war es heute auch beim
motorsport auch an ihrem letzten tag war
diese formel 1 saison ein echter
thriller beziehungsweise einen
nervenkrieg zwischen den dauer-rivalen
max verstappen und lewis hamilton der
niederländer hat dieses duell für sich
entschieden und schien den sieg selbst
kaum fassen zu können volker grube mit
den highlights dieses besonderen
renntages am ende wird es vielleicht
diese geste sein die unvergessen bleibt
ein monatelanger kampf wird in der
letzten runde entschieden
zwei herausragende talente einziger ein
niederländer der erste in der formel 1
geschichte
es ist unglaublich natürlich wo es heute
abend passiert ist natürlich glaube ich
bis jetzt als ist ausgeschaut das ist
natürlich nicht daran nur unsere seite
war den start von der besten
ausgangsposition vermasselt fast daten
konkurrenz und weltmeister lewis
hamilton geht in führung und
kontrolliert das rennen und bis fünf
runden vor schluss scheint der engländer
seinen titel erfolgreich verteidigen zu
können bis latifi in die leitplanken
kraft und eine safety-car-phase auslöst
die rennleitung entscheidet dass die
überrundeten autos die zwischen hamilton
und verstappen fahren überholen dürfen
und so kommt was daten direkt hinter
lewis hamilton in der letzten runde
schafft es fast appen sich an die spitze
zu setzen und gewinnt rennen und titel
mercedes mit teamchef toto wolff sieht
einen regelverstoß in der entscheidung
der rennleitung und legt protest ein
hamilton aber gibt sich zunächst als
fairer verlierer ich
gratuliere max und seinem team
allerdings haben wir bei mercedes auch
eine großartige arbeit geleistet
dem protest des mercedes teams wird
schließlich nicht stattgegeben und so
feiert max daten seinen ersten wm-titel
vor sieben jahren gewann sebastian
vettel den bis heute letzten für red
bull ein erfolg der vater jos verstappen
nie vergönnt war in der formel 1
und wir blicken jetzt noch wie jeden
sonntag auf die kommende woche jörg pohl
hat diesen ausblick zusammengestellt
[Musik]
darauf haben viele familien mit kleinen
kindern gewartet am montag wird mit der
auslieferung des corona impfstoffes für
kinder ab fünf jahren begonnen die stiko
hatte den impfstoff von bayon tag
empfohlen allerdings nur für kinder mit
vorerkrankungen 2,4 millionen dosen
sollen die länder bis jahresende
erhalten
und großer zapfenstreich für annegret
kramp karrenbauer am mittwoch wird die
ehemalige verteidigungsministerin wie
zuletzt die kanzlerin auch von der
bundeswehr verabschiedet spannend wird
sein wie das stabsmusikkorps die
musikwünsche der ex-ministerin
interpretiert
ein eu-gipfel steht an am donnerstag in
brüssel es wird der erste für den neuen
bundeskanzler olaf scholz sein corona
krise ukraine konflikt russland
sanktionen auch auf eu ebene wird scholz
direkt gefordert werden
märz trauen oder röttgen wer wird neuer
cdu parteivorsitzende erstmals durfte
darüber die basis abstimmen das ergebnis
der mitgliederbefragung wird kommenden
freitag vorgestellt die endgültige
entscheidung über den vorsitz wird dann
bei einem digitalen parteitag im januar
fallen
und noch die wetteraussichten zum start
in die neue woche morgen fällt in der
osthälfte etwas regen auch sonst ist es
meist trüb erst am nachmittag zeigt sich
im südwesten und westen kurz die sonne
die temperatur erreicht drei bis zwölf
grad am dienstag kann es im norden
leicht regnen ab mittwoch ist es überall
trocken und dann sehen wir auch die
sonne etwas häufiger die
höchsttemperatur liegt zwischen 2 und 10
grad
das war es mit uns an diesem
sonntagabend gleich geht es mit
inspector barnaby weiter das ja immer
schön zum ablenken von den unbilden
dieser welt 0 30 gibt es dann die
nächste heute express und morgen abend
freuen sich hier bettina schausten und
von der causa auf sie für die sinne
[Musik]